président vous mediène l'algérie
confrontés au problème de la succession
invité de ce journal le professeur
non ça y est il a suivi jusqu'au bout
l'agonie du président algérien d'iran
nouvelle d'émeutes sanglantes à téhéran
les exportations de pétrole sont
interrompus hausse modérée de l' indice
des prix en décembre 0,5 pour cent en un
mois bonsoir depuis 37 jours
pratiquement le monde entier savait que
le président boumédiène était condamné
par les médecins la nouvelle de sa mort
annoncée ce matin à 8h par la radio
algérienne a tout de même provoqué un
choc une très grande émotion en
particulier dans les pays arabes le
président algérien est décédé au petit
matin à l'hôpital mustapha d'alger
son corps a été transporté dans un
fourgon au palais du peuple
et plus d'un millier de personnes qui se
trouvaient aux abords de l'hôpital ont
débordé les cordons de police pour
suivre le cortège dans les minutes qui
ont suivi une marche s'est déroulée
spontanément dans une des principales
avenues de la ville pour rendre hommage
au président boumédiène avant que ne
s'organise l'intérim à la tête de l'état
algérien
c'est donc à 8h ce matin par un flash
d'information à la radio que les
algériens ont appris la mort de houari
boumédiène aussitôt les drapeaux ont été
mis en berne
un deuil national de 40 jours a été
décrété son disque dans la rue dans les
usines dans les bureaux tous les
algériens ne parlait que de la
disparition de leur président il faudra
attendre 10 heures du matin pour que des
manifestations spontanées se forme un
peu partout à alger après le calme et la
dignité de ces derniers jours
les algériens laissaient éclater leur
désespoir avec des scènes frisant
l'hystérie allant même jusqu'à
l'évanouissement
ces scènes vont se produire dans toute
la capitale algérienne
des hommes et des femmes en pleurs
scandant des slogans tels que armée
peuple boumédiène tout
unis pendant ce temps les membres du
conseil de la révolution était à
l'assemblée nationale il rendait hommage
au président moh wengen est proclamée
rabah bitat président par intérim en
principe un délai de 45 jours est prévu
pour organiser l'élection du président
mais il est fort possible que ce délai
soit repoussée pour permettre la tenue
du congrès du fln prévue pour le début
de 1979
c'est le 18 novembre dernier que le
président houari boumédiène a été
hospitalisée dans un état extrêmement
grave à l'hôpital mustapha
il revenait de moscou où il avait été
soigné mais très vite les plus grands
spécialistes mondiaux a couru à son
chevet ont jugé quelques jours plus tard
que son coma était irréversible
d'ailleurs dans les 37 jours qui
viennent de passer nous avons eu du mal
parfois à dégager le vrai du faux dans
les informations qui nous parvenaient de
l'hôpital mustapha
jeudi informations il vaudrait mieux
dire parler de rumeurs on disait qu'il
allait mieux et puis qu'il venait de
mourir
finalement aujourd'hui on est sûr que le
chef de l'état algérien était atteint
d'une sorte de leucémie une très grave
maladie du sang découverte par le
professeur suédois waldenström mais il y
a eu d'autres hypothèses c'est pourquoi
nous vous avons invités sur notre
plateau professeur montagnier ce soir
vous qui êtes chef du service de
réanimation de l'hôpital cochin parce
que vous avez assisté le président
boumédiène jusqu'à ses derniers instants
vous étiez à son chevet il y a quelques
jours encore
et vous étiez au courant de ces diverses
hypothèses alors je crois que si vous
voulez ce qui a été dit comporte une
certaine part de vérité et beaucoup
d'erreurs en définitive on a parlé
énormément de
deux choses différentes de diagnostic
différent il est peut-être intéressant
maintenant justement de faire la part de
ce qui est vrai et de ce qui est faux
comme vous l'avez dit il s'agissait
essentiellement d'une forme particulière
de leucémie en face est une grossière
approximations appelée maladie de
waldenström est en fait d'autres
hypothèses ont été émises qu'il convient
de réfuter on a parlé par exemple de
cancer de la vessie ou de cancer du rein
on a parlé d'erreur transfusionnelle
toutes ces hypothèses sont fausses
on a parlé également d'un attentat qui
aurait entraîné des complications
importantes
j'ai eu l'occasion d'examiner le
président boumediene à multiples
reprises et je peux vous assurer qu'il
n'y avait eu aucune trace de d'armes à
feu par conséquent cette hypothèse là
est également fausse une chose
intéressante peut-être à dire c'est que
on a annoncé sa mort dès le 14 décembre
je crois en tout cas d'une façon
extrêmement prématuré et bien je peux
vous dire puisque je les ai vus encore
très récemment la semaine dernière que
cette annonce était tout à fait
prématuré la semaine dernière il
existait encore une activité électrique
cérébrales importantes
par conséquent le cerveau n'était pas
mort et eu des moments je crois
professeurs ou le plaisir vous veniez
n'a pratiquement retrouvé sa
connaissance alors c'est exact si vous
voulez après la première la première
crise la première attaque pourrait-on
dire est survenu qui a entraîné un coma
est survenue une amélioration est au
bout de 8 à 10 jours pratiquement ne
pouvait dire que la récupération sur le
plan neurologique s'amorcer et à ce
moment-là conscience était redevenue
presque normale en tout cas ils
exécutaient les ordres simples qu'on
pouvait demander c'est à dire qu'il est
serré les mains je crois oui par exemple
si on lui demander de serrer la main il
serrait la main il lever un bras
éventuellement et par conséquent était
avait une communication parfaite si vous
voulez avec l'entourage mais seconde
herman est survenue une deuxième
hémorragie cérébrale qui entraînait un
coma est-ce que
lorsqu'il est rentré à l'hôpital
mustapha il était définitivement
condamnés ou est-ce qu'il avait encore
une chance de le sauver on ne peut pas
dire qu'il était définitivement condamné
si vous voulez si l'on prend chacun des
éléments qui ont concouru à sa maladie
chacun de ces éléments qu'ils soient
neurologie qu'il soit hématologiques
qu'ils soient rénale qu'il soit que ce
soit des problèmes d'autres problèmes
généraux chacun des éléments étaient
susceptibles d'une légère amélioration
ne peut pas parler de guérison mais il
était absolument évident que chacun des
éléments pouvaient s'améliorer
il s'est produit une amélioration sur le
plan neurologique il s'est produit une
amélioration sur le plan rénale est sur
le plan des conditions générales et la
maladie de base elle-même les mots pâtit
sous jacente qui étaient susceptibles
non pas de guérison mais au moins
d'amélioration et de régression partiel
avait pu lire complètement le dossier
médical de du président boumédiène est
ce que vous pouvez déterminer quelles
ont été les causes de sa maladie et
depuis quand est-il malade alors depuis
quand il était malade
les premières manifestations de sa
maladie remonte aux environs du 18
septembre
il était alors en syrie et il a présenté
une fatigue intense une asthénie
extrêmement marqué qui l'ont conduit à
revenir en algérie plusieurs jours
cutter s'est produit une hématurie c'est
à dire la présence de sang dans les
urines qui a motivé son départ à moscou
où il nous restait mais à son retour du
reste est il se savait déjà condamné
alors je crois que là c'est un point
extrêmement important et je crois que
l'on peut dire d'une façon quasi
certaine que lorsqu'il est revenu de
russie
il savait que son pronostic était fatal
à plus ou moins brève échéance
donc on peut dire que au moment où il
est parti au dessus de la france et où
il a envoyé ce fameux message de
sympathie et d'amitié au président
français il connaissait déjà son
diagnostic il se savait déjà condamné
c'est une cela donne une certaine un
premier pas seulement une hypothèse je
crois que c'est une quasi certitude on
peut revenir à ce qui se passe à
l'hôpital mustapha alger comment ça se
passait entre vous vous étiez même
plusieurs dizaines de médecins
spécialistes mondiaux parliez pas la
même langue
comment ça se passait alors je peux tout
d'abord vous dire que toutes les
discussions pratiquement avait lu en
français toutes les observations étaient
tenus en français par les médecins
algériens
m il est évident que surtout au début il
y avait énormément de médecins présents
mais en fait tous les médecins n'avaient
pas le même rôle certain si vous voulez
étudier le problème du malade dans un
amphithéâtre où l'on venait deux ou
trois fois par jour faire le bilan
clinique et biologique mais de tout ce
qui se produisait et il y avait là une
discussion une exposés d'abord une
discussion ensuite qu'ils étaient
relativement si vous voulez un peu
académique mais quels étaient les
médecins qui approchait véritablement
alors le président vous m'aidiez parmi
les médecins qui approchait
véritablement le président il y avait
bien entendu le professeur brief qui est
le chef du service de réanimation
polyvalente de l'hôpital mustapha et
toute son équipe tous ses résidents
qu'ils sont des médecins je dois le dire
de une grande qualité d'une grande
compétence et qui sont tout à fait
passionnés par leur métier et les
médecins français
alors il y avait aussi des médecins
français qui sont ceux qui se sont
relayés me presque en permanence et qui
ont parfaitement collaboré avec les
médecins algériens
je dois dire qu'un des souvenirs les
plus les plus remarquables que je ramène
cible et c'est justement cette
collaboration tout à fait particulière
entre les médecins français et les
médecins algériens
qui a été très très efficace sur le plan
des faits est ce qu'à un moment donné
vous d'autres médecins ont subi des
pressions de la part du gouvernement des
autorités algériennes pour maintenir
dans un état de vie artificielle
le président boumédiène parce que cela
pouvait arranger les choses
politiquement je ne peux pas vous dire
ce qu'il en est des autres médecins je
peux simplement vous dire ce que ce
qu'il en est en ce qui me concerne je
n'étais l'objet d'aucune pression
d'aucune sorte ni pour prolonger d'une
façon excessive civile et le président
ce qui n'a pas été le cas ni de pression
pour dire où pour ne pas dire ce que
j'avais constaté de ce côté là vraiment
aucune pression d'aucune sorte
professeur mans ça y est nous vous
remercions pour ce témoignage
exceptionnel le chef de l'état algérien
qui repose actuellement au palais du
peuple sera inhumé vendredi prochain 29
décembre
les funérailles nationales seront
célébrées ce jour-là et un deuil
national de 40 jours a été décrété sur
l'ensemble du territoire algérien houari
boumédiène vendredi sera enterré dans un
cimetière près d'alger à quelques pas de
là tombe d'abdelkader l'une des grandes
gloires de l'histoire de l'algérie
le président boumédiène avait d'ailleurs
dans son bureau au dessus de sa table de
travail un portrait d'adele khadr le
symbole de la continuité de l'algérie
sans se tromper évidemment il est facile
de dire que houari boumédiène à son tour
entre de plain pied dans l'histoire
algérienne
edouard leur 1962 après sept années de
lutte
l'algérie fait son indépendance
à la tête du pays le gpr gouvernement
provisoire de la république algérienne
qui se donne comme premier chef de
l'algérie indépendante
son leader historique benbella à ses
côtés son plus fidèle compagnon houari
boumédiène boumédiène a su prendre et
donner des gages à benguela lorsqu'il
était encore prisonniers des français
par bouteflika interposés bouteflika
était vraiment le lien entre boumédiène
et ben bella ensuite après après la
guerre naturellement il y aura des
problèmes il reprochera à ben bella de
beaucoup trop parlé d' être démagogue
alors que boumédiène savait son
véritable nom c'est mme ahmed boukraâ
kharouba et ont traduit houari
boumédiène par grands vieux jeune homme
mince et fin et bien c'est tout cela
plus la tête
fidèle compagnon jusqu'en 65 benbella
est arrêté en pleine nuit
incarcéré depuis dans une résidence
secrète vous mediène prend le pouvoir
nomme un conseil de la révolution dont
il prend la présidence des militaires
mais aussi des ministres civils la
plupart de ceux qui avaient choisi ben
bella lui même
pour montrer un petit peu comment
quelles sortes de personnages et
boumédiène et bien il sait très bien
qu'il va falloir pour faire son coup
d'état qu'il y ait du monde dans la rue
toullier l'armée eh bien il va profiter
du tournage du film la bataille d'alger
où l'on reconstitue en plein coeur
d'alger
tout ce qui a été la lutte entre les
parachutistes et les fellaghas et on
croira que les chars sont des chars de
figuration en réalité ce sont les chars
du coup d'état l'algérie avait besoin
d'autres choses avaient besoin d'ordre
avait besoin de discipline avait besoin
d'une grande remise en ordre d'une
restructuration d'une unification
unification d'un regroupement dans le
groupe monde de toutes les forces
révolutionnaires elles avaient besoin
c'était page jeunes avaient besoin aussi
d'une certaine moralité et certainement
l'arrêter pour pouvoir s'imposer en tant
qu'etat
le premier objectif de boumédiène un
programme d'austérité très strict pour
remonter l'économie du pays et son
premier geste politique les élections
municipales pour la première fois les
femmes algériennes potes
1967 la rencontre au caire avec nasser
l'homme que boumédiène aura sans doute
le plus admiré dans le monde arabe
1967 c'est aussi la veille de la guerre
des six jours
paradoxalement l'algérie sortir en
position de force au lendemain du cessez
le feu le colonel boumédiène retrouve
son armée attaque
soixante dix mille hommes armés et
équipés par les soviétiques qui n'ont
pas eu eux à s'opposer directement aux
israéliens
ainsi un mois après le cessez-le-feu
boumédiène se retrouve au caire aux
côtés de la serre et des présidents de
syrie et d'irak pour refuser
catégoriquement toute négociation avec
israël et décidé de renforcer l'embargo
sur le pétrole à destination des
etats-unis de la grande-bretagne et de
l'allemagne de l'ouest 1972 boumédiène
entreprend un vaste programme de
réformes pour l'algérie révolution
agraire
on distribue aux paysans les terres du
secteur privé passer au secteur public
avec titres de propriété tout à fait
officiel révolution industrielle aussi
le pétrole l'or noir finances 1 90% d'un
plan qui doit permettre en quatre ans à
l'algérie de se doter d'une
infrastructure industrielle
on a beaucoup parlé de la crise a
toujours attribue cette crise au
problème de l'énergie
je crois que les origines de la crise
réside dans l'injustice même dans
l'organisation même du monde
actuelle nous sommes les plus nombreux
nous sommes le réservoir en réservoir
des matières premières et même de
l'amande heures nous représentants a
marché très vaste très vaste pour les
industriels des pays développés donc à
régler ses problèmes en dehors de nous
c'est une url click saute la réalité la
vérité brand temporel 1974 ou haribo
mediène comme la plupart des grands
chefs d'état se rend à pékin
rencontre avec mao sur le même thème la
lutte contre l'impérialisme
mais aussi la même année à washington
avec nixon pour renouer des relations
diplomatiques interrompues depuis sept
ans
et en avril 75 accueillant valéry
giscard d'estaing premier chef d'état
français à se rendre en visite
officielle à alger depuis l'indépendance
un premier contact
une première tentative de réconciliation
avec la france
et
en deux mots je peux dire qu'aujourd'hui
tout est possible en temps de latence
cite une phrase qui peut tous aller j'y
vais mais seuls nous ne pourrons pas
tout faire
enfin la dernière apparition sur la
scène internationale la conférence de
tripoli avec aux côtés de boumédiène les
principaux leaders du front du refus
le libyen kadhafi le syrien assad et le
palestinien raafat la condamnation
formelle de l'algérie aux tentatives de
réconciliation entre l'egypte et israël
il faut créer les bases matérielles
d'une véritable renaissance arabe et
j'entends par là
la base matérielle il faut créer une
économie modèle il faut instruire tous
les citoyens tous les gosses ah ben il
faut multiplier les universités
multiplier les instituts créés la secte
ur comines dans tout le temps tout le
dans tous les domaines hamon avait cessé
ses la regrettable pour nous et pour moi
personnellement c'est la véritable
orientation aussi cette orientation qui
peut mener à une véritable renaissance
toute la journée des messages de
condoléances et d'amitié sont arrivés à
alger beaucoup de chefs d'état et
d'hommes politiques ont commenté la mort
de houari boumédiène et plusieurs pays
arabes ont décrété des deuils nationaux
de paris le président valéry giscard
d'estaing a déclaré dans un télégramme à
monsieur rabattre beat ap le président
par intérim
la france que tant de liens ont uni à
l'algérie est proche d'elle en ce moment
d'épreuve
le président boumédiène laissera dans
l'histoire de son pays le souvenir d'un
homme d'état dont l'art dans deux
volontés s'était fixé pour objectif de
placer l'algérie dans les premiers rangs
de ceux qui s'illustrent sur la scène
internationale mais sur raymond barre et
jean françois poncet ont également
envoyé leurs condoléances à monsieur
beat ap le parti socialiste a salué la
mémoire du président algérien
une délégation du parti communiste
français s'est rendu à l'ambassade
d'algérie à paris pour y remettre un
message de condoléances de la part de
monsieur marché puis jacques chirac a
également envoyé un télégramme
nous aurons l'occasion de revenir sur
toutes ces réactions mais dès ce soir je
pense que l'on peut se poser une
question à savoir de quelle façon la
succession va s'organiser paul nahon oui
justement je crois qu'il faut dire il
faut répéter répéter c'est important que
le président boumédiène n'a pas eu le
temps de son vivant sublet de préparer
activement sa succession la maladie qui
l'emportait était absolument effroyable
et foudroyante alors en revanche pendant
six semaines de coma du président de la
république algérienne sexus et soeurs le
concède la révolution on tue le temps si
vous voulez de préparer
psychologiquement l'opinion publique
algérienne et de préparer surtout
l'avenir du pays mais est-ce que dès ce
soir paul nahon on peut avancer des noms
ses successeurs théoriquement les
successeurs ne manquent pas si vous
voulez pour schématiser il ya en ce
moment j'ai lu d' influence terrible
entre les partisans et ceux qui comme le
colonel yahiaoui qui contrôle le parti
le fln et qui voudraient poursuivre la
ligne médiane c'est à dire l'algérie
leader du tiers monde des pays
non-alignés du dialogue entre l'europe
et l'afrique du clan du refus et les
partisans comme l'actuelle mini des
affaires étrangères monsieur bouteflika
qui voudraient ouvrir le pays un peu
plus vers l'occident
mais quoi qu'il en soit une chose est
absolument certaine à rien ne pourra
être fait sans l'armée ou contre l'armée
actuellement tous les ministres
importants du gouvernement algérien sur
des militaires et houari boumédiène
était à la fois ministre la défense est
contrôlé à la fois la gendarmerie et la
police
enfin actuellement dans ses problèmes
difficiles et de la succession les
relations mais très délicat passionnel
même avec la france au centre des
préoccupations des dirigeants algériens
et je crois qu'il faut rappeler les
propos du professeur monsallier tout à
l'heure qui s'est rendu cinq fois au
chevet du président boumédiène le
professeur mansaly est formel le
président boumédiène en partant d'union
soviétique se savait condamné et il a
choisi en revenant mourir en algérie de
lancer en survolant la france un message
au président de la république française
dans lequel il exprime son espoir pour
de meilleures relations entre la france
et l'algérie
c'est le dernier message public de
houari boumédiène pour la france
peut-être une partie de son testament
politique pour son successeur lui dans
l'actualité de ce mercredi 27 décembre
il ya également à l'étranger
l'iran la situation en iran téhéran la
capitale a repris son visage des jours
d'émeutes patrouille militaire des chars
aux quatre coins de la ville et de très
graves accrochages encore entre des
soldats et des manifestants selon
l'opposition il y aurait entre 5 et 15
morts la situation économique elle
continue de se dégrader pour la première
fois dans son histoire récente
l'iran a complètement cessé ses
exportations de pétrole
c'est la conséquence des grèves des
ouvriers dans ce secteur et cela
pourrait avoir des retombées
catastrophiques pour ce pays nous sommes
ici à la raffinerie de pétrole de
téhéran elle est en grève plus ou moins
continue depuis trois mois comme
l'ensemble de la production pétrolière
iranienne
circonstance aggravante hier quatre
mille deux cents ouvriers de la
raffinerie d'abadan l'une des plus
grandes du monde ont démissionné
collectivement pour protester contre les
menaces de procès qui était faite aux
grévistes
premier pays touché l'afrique du sud 90%
de son pétrole provient dire en israël
et la grande bretagne
mais pour la france pas de problème le
pétrole iranien ne représentent 9% de
nos approvisionnements et vu l'état de
nos stocks
la crise iranienne pourrait durer trois
ans sans que notre consommation en soit
affectée sur le plan intérieur aussi
l'arrêt quasi total de la production
provoque de sérieux problèmes et c'est
tout le petit peuple iranien qui en
souffrent le plus le fioul domestique
est devenu introuvable
les appartements ne sont plus chauffés
et dans toutes les grandes villes
c'est ce spectacle de queues
interminables devant les postes
d'essence
après les manifestations c'est donc la
deuxième étape de la lutte que mène la
religion chiite contre le pouvoir
la grève dans le secteur pétrolier est
un acte d'obéissance à dieu affirmé il
ya quelques jours l'ayatollah khomeini
le pillage des richesses de la nation
est ainsi stoppée pas de doute
l'iran s'enfonce dans la crise mais pour
le moment ce sont les iraniens qui en
sont les premières victimes
l'iran c'est un des sujets de
conversation que monsieur jean françois
poncet a eu au koweït au koweït où les
dirigeants se sont dits préoccupés par
la situation sur place une situation qui
pourrait avoir des répercussions sur les
pays voisins notamment en irak
jean françois poncet a quitté koweït cet
après midi il est arrivé à abou dhabi
pour une visite officielle de 48 heures
dans les émirats arabes unis et là
encore on devrait parler du pétrole mais
aussi du proche orient et à ce propos le
président égyptien sadate s'est déclaré
cet après-midi optimiste pour une
reprise prochaine des négociations de
paix avec israël
la réunion de bruxelles a été très utile
at il dit il existe une chance pour un
nouveau round de négociations tout sera
clair d'ici deux jours a expliqué en
résumé monsieur sadate cet après midi en
espagne paraphe royal pour la nouvelle
constitution approuvée par référendum le
6 décembre dernier le roi juan carlos a
signé ce matin au cours d'une cérémonie
solennelle célébrée aux cortès le texte
de la constitution qui entrera
officiellement en vigueur dans deux
jours le 29 décembre
la dernière cérémonie de ce genre
remonte à plus de 100 ans puisque le roi
alphonse 12 avait été en juin 1876 le
dernier souverain espagnol a sanctionné
une constitution la france maintenant
l'actualité en france avec tout d'abord
ces chiffres à la publication de la
hausse des prix au mois de novembre
c'est 0,5 pour cent c'est le meilleur
score depuis le début de l'année
pratiquement dehors du mois de janvier
permis à reykjavik
oui c'est toujours une bonne chose quand
les prix n'augmentent pas trop vite mais
ce bond à 10 2 novembre est aussi
quelque chose qui va un petit peu plus
loin s'il est bon c'est notamment parce
que les prix des produits manufacturés
c'est-à-dire dans l'industrie ont été
raisonnables et je vous rappelle que
depuis l'été dernier
ces prix ne sont plus contrôlés [ __ ]
par le gouvernement ils sont libres pour
la plupart et chaque mois on craint
toujours un peu que les chefs
d'entreprise n'ont amusé depuis quatre
mois ils n'ont pas abusé puisque depuis
quatre mois au total 2 7% de hausse des
prix pour vous donner une idée si on
tenait ce rythme toute l'année on fera
un score de 8 et quelques pour cent pour
l'année ce qui serait tout neuf
enfin on n'en est pas encore là il a
encore maté sens n'en est pas encore là
et puis 9,2 pour cent depuis le 1er
janvier c'est tout de même assez élevé
il reste donc un chiffre à connaître
pour avoir le total 1978 en général
traditionnellement l' indice de décembre
n'est pas très élevé il faudrait qu'ils
fassent donc 0,8 pour cent pour
atteindre ce fameux chiffre de 10%
c'était fameuse hausse des prix à deux
chiffres qui est tellement mal vu de
tous les gouvernements mais aussi de
toutes les opinions publiques
c'est désormais peu probable c'est la
raison pour laquelle ce bond à 10 2
novembre est un petit peu plus qu'un
chapitre simple les chiffres mensuels
c'est aussi un bon signe pour l'avenir
à la page sociale également à longwy en
meurthe et moselle suite de l'opération
routes bleues qu'est aujourd'hui les
habitants de la ville et des syndicats
protestent je vous le rappelle contre la
suppression de 6400 50 emplois dans la
sidérurgie par d'incident les barrages
seront levés demain à 10h politique une
petite phrase à retenir celle de
monsieur arthur notebart député
socialiste du nord qui a décidé lui
aussi de présenter une motion au
prochain congrès du parti socialiste à
metz le parti socialiste at il dit doit
dire qu'un programme commun n'est plus
concevable temps que le parti communiste
s'alignera systématiquement sur l'union
soviétique
monsieur notebart propose un dialogue
idéologique avec le parti communiste a
sorti d'un pacte de non-agression et
puis à la rubrique vie pratique
maintenant sachez que la ratp la régie
autonome des transports parisiens vient
d'accueillir son 2 milliardième
voyageurs cela n'a pas été simple pour
la retrouver pour la retrouver j'ai bien
dit puisqu'il s'agit de madame pierron
qui habite à noisy-le-grand
la ratp a utilisé un ordinateur deux
milliards de voyageurs en 1978 cela
place la régie ou au troisième rang du
transport urbain après moscou et tokyo
et puis les suites de la grande panne
d'électricité le pdg de l'edf monsieur
de l'ouvrier vient d'envoyer une lettre
à son directeur général monsieur boiteux
de lettre dans laquelle il estime qu'il
faudra un certain temps pour déterminer
les origines précises de la panne du 19
décembre
parmi les causes évoquées par l'edf il y
à la confusion entre ce que l'on appelle
le tout électrique et l'installation de
chauffage électrique d'appoint
l'électricité de france de toutes façons
exprime ses regrets à ses clients
le grand retour à la bougie à la lampe à
huile les habitants de certaines
communes de lozère et de l'ardèche le
cône est encore en ce moment puisqu'ils
sont privés d'électricité
non pas à cause de la grande panne mais
tout simplement parce que d'importantes
chutes de neige ont isolé ces
départements en endommageant les lignes
électriques
l'armée qui le df ont dû intervenir pour
venir au secours des habitats à la
limite de ces départements de la lozère
de la haute loire et de l'ardèche 3000
poteaux électriques ont été abattus
depuis mercredi dernier par la neige
dans cette région dit aujourd'hui pays
du bout du monde
des lignes téléphoniques sont également
coupées trayeuse et congélateurs arrêté
télévision en rade celle isolement à
quelques heures de paris l' isolement de
chaque hiver est aussi une question
posée
peut-on échapper dans ces communes aux
dégâts de la mauvaise saison
l'ardèche de l'ouest celle des hauts
plateaux près du lac issa relais
particulièrement touché les df essaie de
réparer le réseau et des groupes
électrogènes ont été mises en place dans
ces villages qui se dépeuple depuis
plusieurs années ont fait remarquer que
cet isolement provoqué par 80 cm de
neige ne retiendra pas au pays
les jeunes qui fuit depuis longtemps
vers les grandes villes pour le paysan
c'est le retour au mode traditionnel de
traite des vaches à la main mais ces
images de l'ibère dans ces départements
agricoles a aujourd'hui des reflets
inquiétant voilà cela n'amène tout droit
vous parlez des prévisions météo pour la
journée de demain jeudi
bah ce n'est pas très très favorable car
il y aura encore des pluies matinales
des pluies matinales sur les régions de
l'est et du sud est ensuite
généralisation du temps variable avec
alternance d'éclaircies et de nuages
donnant des pluies et des averses près
de l'atlantique et du midi les hommes
des averses seront localement
accompagnées d'orages les éclaircies sur
- bell près de la manche et dans la mer
du nord et les vents vont devenir forts
en particulier près des côtes en raison
du mauvais temps d'ailleurs mauvais
temps qui règne en ce moment sur toute
l'espagne guise aéroports espagnols
viennent d'être fermée de façon
temporaire
cela n'a rien à voir avec la météo mais
la marine nationale a décidé d'arrêter
les recherches concernant alain colas
l'effort exceptionnel accompli jusqu'à
maintenant ne peut être
définitivement poursuivie explique le
ministère de la défense 36 missions de
breguet atlantique c'est à dire 450
heures de vols ont été effectués depuis
le 16 novembre dernier le jour du
dernier contact avec le navigateur
solitaire
bien évidemment les unités navales ou
aériennes des armées qui seront en
service dans l'atlantique nord resteront
en veille
attentif et puis dans l'actualité un
accident spectaculaire d'un camion près
de nice un semi-remorque italien de 38
tonnes a fait une chute de 30 mètres à
l'entrée d'une autoroute il est tombé
sur trois maisons dans les habitants
sont sortis miraculeusement indemne il
ya tout de même un mort le chauffeur du
camion et son passager a été blessé
pour terminer ce journal nous allons
examiner un conflit du travail qui est à
mi chemin entre la page sociale et la
page spectacle puisqu'il s'agit de
l'opéra de paris
la grève déclenchée au palais garnier
empêchant pour l'instant les
représentations du lac du cygne mais
cette grève a été reconduite jusqu'à
demain en attendant d'ailleurs le vote
d'une nouvelle assemblée générale du
personnel et cette grève nous intéresse
au plus haut point new antenne 2 puisque
vous savez que le dernier grand
échiquier de jacques chancel dernier
grand échiquier de l'année sera
consacrée demain soir à l'opéra de paris
alors avant toute chose les faits avec
leur ambassade y est les machinistes les
accessoiristes et le personnel des
ateliers de construction de l'opéra de
paris ont donc décidé de continuer la
grève commencée il ya six à l'origine du
conflit
le licenciement de 50 machinistes à la
suite du démontage d'un décor lors d'une
représentation du 21 décembre une faute
lourde selon la direction mais pour le
personnel une mesure conforme aux règles
de sécurité
en réalité la situation à l'opéra
restent tendues depuis plusieurs mois et
n'est pas sans rappeler le conflit qui
avait duré trois semaines fin 75 des bus
76 à l'époque les spectacles a vite eu
lieu sans décor mais aujourd'hui les
syndicats durcissent leurs positions en
menaçant d'occuper la scène s'il
représentations sont maintenus lui
demande la réintégration des 50
machinistes et l'ouverture de
négociations salariales
conséquence directe au palais garnier
annulation jusqu'à nouvel ordre du lac
des cygnes et vendredi 29 journées
d'action dans les théâtres nationaux et
privés entraînant des retards au lever
de rideau voilà donc pour les flèches
les fêtes plutôt concernant ce conflit
au palais garnier par sur antenne 2 dans
votre grand échiquier jacques chancel
que va-t-il se passer demain soir
d'abord il faudrait donner une précision
on pourrait s'étonner demain que nous ne
parlions pas de cette crise de l'opéra
mais cela pour une bonne raison
d'abord cette émission pour une fois été
enregistrés dans sa totalité et cela a
été une forme d'exploit dans le sens où
si aujourd'hui nous décidions de faire
une émission sur l'opéra de paris à
partir du moment où le décide il
faudrait attendre 1982 pour pouvoir la
réaliser pour une seule et bonne raison
c'est que nous avons demandé trois jours
d'arrêt à l'opéra et je crois que l'on
peut dire que si nous avons pu réaliser
cette émission dans les d'excellentes
conditions c'est parce que d'abord
lieberman mais assure anna était
d'accord mais surtout aussi parce que
tous les syndicats se sont associés ont
été nos complices dans cette affaire je
tiens à le dire
donc demain puisque l'émission est ce
tellement enregistré que nous venons de
terminer de lamotte et nous n'aurons pas
ce problème que pourrait entraîner la
crise si nous étions en direct
donc nous nous réjouissons de pouvoir se
présenter ce spectacle qui est annoncé
mais nous pensons très sincèrement tout
ce qui se passe je crois que le
spectacle pourra faire penser à cette
grande maison d'opéra qui est une
superbe entreprise jacques chancel vous
êtes aussi responsable des programmes de
fin d'année sur antenne 2 est ce que
vous êtes satisfait de la façon dont ça
s'est déroulé d'abord moi je ne suis
jamais satisfait lundi
non mais on peut faire quelques
constatations bien sûr il y eut des
émissions était belle de frank la soirée
de noël
le par exemple ou trois jérusalem ou
trois regards et la veillée à saint
séverin et est vraiment constitué une
très bonne soirée
doit-on le dire par les comédiens de la
comédie française c'est un très beau
spectacle ce qu'a fait anne sylvestre
pour les enfants étaient boubou miliana
syrie gaston fébus la série sam et
selick nous verrons tout à l'heure mais
si vous le permettez je fais une
constatation mais c'est un c'est une
réflexion que l'on pourrait peut-être un
jour porter beaucoup plus loin qui
intéresse toute la télévision je
m'aperçois que les films les moins bons
pour les plus gros scores
alors posons un point d'interrogation la
télévision est ce le cinéma il faut
aider le cinéma et nous le faisons je
crois de la manière la plus la plus
totale mais parfois on comprend certains
réalisateurs au comprendre certains
producteurs et on comprend certains
responsables de télévision lorsque
regarde dans les sondages qu'il ne faut
jamais regarder parce que il ne faut pas
travailler au sondage on s'aperçoit
quand même que les plus beaux scores
sont réalisées par des choses qui
n'étaient pas toujours tout à fait
convenable est-ce qu'on n'a pas un peu
tort de tous braqués les projecteurs sur
la fin de l'année non même cage et or ne
l'a pas fait cette année l'année
dernière on pouvait nous accuser de cela
et elle est à juste raison c'est à dire
que par exemple nous avions ou couper
toute une série dramatique si klose est
qu'un film se trouvait devant une
dramatique de très haute qualité la
dramatique forcément était je dirais
presque tué entre guillemets pas par le
film cette fois ci nous avons joué la
carte totale du divertissement en
pensant que la fin de l'année et un
espace dans lequel forcément on peut
être diverti sommet ça dépasse le seul
espace d'une année c'est à dire l'année
continue et le programme est une unité
totale qui va du 1er janvier au 31
décembre
rendez vous demain soir pour votre grand
échiquier à 20h30 sur antenne 2 vous
avez un autre rendez-vous dans la soirée
vers 23h30 avec hervé claude pour le
dernier journal sur notre mais nous même
chaîne fontaine de nous avons été un peu
long il est 20 heures 35 mais actualité
oblige je fait une très belle soirée sur
antenne 2